Merhabalar
hoş geldiniz
iklim değişikliği temalı bir
toplantıdayız herkes az çok iklim
değişikliğiyle biliyor ben size Aslında
güzel güzel slaytlar hazırlamıştım
teknik aksaklık nedeniyle olmadı Ama
şundan bahsetmek istiyorum ben iklim
değişikliğine biraz daha farklı bakmak
istiyorum bundan 10 yıl önce ya kadar
böyle bir konuşmalarda şunu anlatırdık
İklim Değişikliği var bakın şunlar
şunlar oluyor iklim değişikliği Bunlara
sebep oluyor diye artık iklim
kağıtçıları dediğimiz kimse kalmadı
Herkes iklim değişikliğini olduğunu
biliyor ama iklim değişikliğini nasıl
konuşuyoruz nereden konuşuyoruz bunlara
bakmamız lazım genellikle şöyle
konuşuyoruz işte iklim değişikliği oldu
Seller kuraklıklar orman yangınları
heyelanlar çığlar ve bunların insanlar
üzerindeki etkisi üzerinden gidiyoruz
Hatta iklim değişikliğini Günah Keçisi
yapıyoruz nasıl yapıyoruz bir şey olduğu
zaman bir afiyet olduğu zaman
Ee bunu suçlusu iklim değişikliği deyip
suçu iklim değişikliğine Ee yükleyerek
Ne yapalım İklim Değişikliği var bu
afetler oluyor diyoruz ve Aslında mesela
afet dediğimiz şeyde de nedir biliyor
musunuz afet dediğiniz şeyde Ee aşırı
hava olayları yani iklim değişikliğine
bağlı olarak sıklığı şiddeti süresi
artan aşırı hava olaylarının can ve mal
kaybına neden olması durumunda Bunlar
afet olarak nitelendiriliyor Örneğin hiç
insanın yaşamadığı dağ başında hiç
olmuyor mu
ya da dağın başında bir Orman yandı
belki haberiniz daha iyi olmuyor onlar
afet olarak değerlendirilmiyor
özetle Biz iklim değişikliğini hep
insanlar etkisi üzerinden konuşuyoruz
yani işte şu kadar kişi öldü bu kadar
ekonomik kayboldu Hatta işte Gayri safi
milli hasılaya yüzde Bilmem kaçı kadar
zararı var diyerek politikacılar ikna
etmeye çalışıyoruz ama
dünyada yalnız mıyız bazen böyle şey de
vardır yani hep uzayda yalnız mıyız diye
Sorulur Ya bırakın uzayı dünyada yalnız
değiliz yani Dünya sadece insanlardan
oluşmuyor
30 milyon mu 20 milyon mu bilmiyoruz ama
iki nokta bildiğimiz iki nokta bir
milyon kadar canlı türü ile bu dünyayı
paylaşıyoruz peki hani Bizler iklim
değişikliğinden etkileniyoruz diğer
canlılar bu iklim değişikliğinden
etkilenmiyor mu size bunlardan Birkaç
tanesinin hikayesini anlatmak istiyorum
çünkü bütün canlılar her bir o iki nokta
bir milyon kürün her bir şekilde iklim
değişikliğinden etkileniyor
slaytlar olsaydı görecektiniz Caretta
carettaları biliyor musunuz
deniz kaplumbağası dev
efendim
ne güzel Hatta bir de Türkiye'de şey de
var Yeşil Deniz kaplumbağası var keloia
Midas diye bakın iklim değişikliği
biliyorsunuz Bu Kaplumbağalar
kumsallara yuva yapıyorlar ve bu
kumsallarda yuva yaptıkları yuvanın
sıcaklığı O yumurtadan çıkan minik
kaplumbağa yavrularının cinsiyetini
etkiliyor Dünya üzerinde böyle cinsiyeti
sıcaklığa bağlı olan türler var o
caretta caretta ve kelonya midaslar
bunlardan
sıcaklığın kum sıcaklığını o yuva
sıcaklığını sadece 1 santigrat derece
artması durumunda yuvadan çıkan
bireylerin %90 dişi oluyor
30 dereceden 31 dereceye çıktığı zaman
yuva sıcaklığı %90'ı dişi oluyor şimdi
sadece sıcaklık artışı
bu türün nefsini sağlıklı olarak devam
ettirmesi mümkün mü Değil bakın doğrudan
bu şekilde iklim değişikliği türleri
etkiliyor şeye girmedim
bunda Kaplumbağalar
kumullara kumsallara bizim plaj olarak
gördüğümüz yerleri yapıyor ya peki Deniz
seviyeleri yükseliyor Deniz seviyeleri
yükseldiği zaman bu plajlarda sular
altında kalabilir Kumrular da sular
altında kalabilir hep Deniz seviyeleri
yükselmesini böyle pasifikte oluyormuş
gibi düşünüyoruz ama pasifik'te olmuyor
Türkiye'de de yılda ortalama 3 mm kadar
yükseliyor Deniz seviyeleri ki 20
santime kadar yükseldi son 100 yıl
içinde
peki
iklim değişikliğinin türleri üzerindeki
etkisi deyince sembolleşmiş hangi hayvan
aklınıza geliyor
Koalalar kutup ayıları değil mi böyle
Sembol parçalanmış bir buzun üstünde aç
kalmış bir Kutup ayısını düşünüyorsunuz
değil mi
Peki ülkemizdeki Ayılar ne durumda
ülkemizde yok mu ülkemizde de boz ayı
var ve
sıcaklıklar bütün canlıların her
hareketini belirleyen en önemli
mitolojik faaliyetlerden de meteorolojik
özelliklerdendir Örneğin Baharda
Bitkiler ne zaman çiçek açar tamamen
sıcaklıklarla ilgili ya da Göçmen Kuşlar
ne zaman göç ederler tamamen
sıcaklıklarla ilgili ya da ayılardan
bahsediyordum Boz Ayılar Kış uykusuna
yatarlar biliyorsunuz Kış uykusuna
yatacakları nereden bilirler sıcaklıklar
Peki son yıllarda kış aylarında
sıcaklıklarını arttığı görüyoruz değil
mi biliyoruz hissediyoruz Peki sıcak kış
mevsimine sıcaklıklar artarsa bu ayılar
ne yapar
Yatmıyorlar
yatmayınca Bu sefer de kış uykusuna
yatmayınca yiyecek aramak zorunda
kalıyorlar
ve biz insanlar onların yaşam alanlarına
girdiğimiz için bu sefer de insan ve ayı
çatışması olarak adlandırdığımız
sorunlarla karşılaşıyoruz Bu bir örnek
buna benzer çok sayıda örnek verebiliriz
Örneğin
bu sene gördünüz mü yani bu sene hiç
dikkat ettiniz mi
Ocak ayında İstanbul'da
bitkiler çiçek açtı Geçen sene de açmış
tım niye çiçek açtı Çünkü inanılmaz
sıcak bir kış ayı yaşadık biliyor
musunuz bitkilerin de
çiçek açması için sıcaklıkların belli
dereceye çıkması lazım ağaçlar için bu
yaklaşık bir aylık bir sürede ortalama
sıcaklığın 10 santigracı civarında
olması gerekiyor o süt ürünleri için 5
derece civarında çıkarsa bir aylık
ortalama sıcaklık Bahar Geldi
zannediyorlar ve Bahar geldiği için de
çiçekleniyorlar Hatta ben buna Yalancı
Bahar diyorum dizi ismi gibi ee evet
kanıyorlar sıcaklıkların ısınmasını ve
birdenbire Kışın ortasında çiçek
açıyorlar sonra ne oluyor hava
sıcaklıkları düştüğü zaman
etkileniyorlar Hatta size şöyle bir şey
söyleyeyim
tropikal bölgeleri biliyorsunuz değil mi
yılın 12 ayı yani kış mevsim yoktur
yılın 12 ayı
bitkiler büyümeye devam ederler
Durmaz yani kış uykusuna girmez bitkiler
Ege ve Akdeniz'de de gelecekte kış
aylarında sıcaklıklar 10 derecenin
altına düşmezse bütün kış mevsim boyunca
bitkiler kış uykusuna yatmadan
kalabilirler
başka neler var mesela Bir de yılan
balığı hikayesinden bahsetmek istiyorum
yılan balığı yani iklim değişikliği
doğrudan canlılar etkilediği gibi
dolaylı olarak da etkilenebilir yılan
balığını bileniniz var mı
ülkemizde var Tatlı sularda göllerde
akarsular değişiyor çok ilginç bir canlı
yaklaşık yani 30-40 yıl 50 yıl kadar
yaşayabiliyor
ömrünün sonunda dişi balıklar dişi yılan
balıkları göç ediyorlar tatlı sulardan
çıkıp denizlere gidiyorlar ve 7.000
kilometrelik bir mesafeye katediyorlar
Örneğin bizim Ege Akdeniz'de Örneğin
Bafa Gölü'nde var Bafa Gölü'nden çıkıyor
Menderes'e ulaşıyor Oradan ta Meksika
körfezine gidiyorlar orada
yumurtluyorlar çıkan yavrular da
Yaklaşık 3 yıl süren bir yolculuktan
sonra tekrardan bizim sularımıza geliyor
müthiş bir hikaye nereden biliyorlar
nasıl geliyorlar onlara Girmeyeceğim ama
diyelim ki
ülkemizde de kuraklıklardan bahsediyoruz
kuraklık deyince hep İstanbul'un
barajları üzerinden konuşuyoruz ya
İstanbul'un barajlarında vesaire Peki
kuraklıklar ile birlikte akarsulardaki
su seviyesi azalırsa ne olur
o akarsular denize Atmazsa ne olur işte
bu gibi türler akarsulardan denize
çıkamazlar yani denizler ve tatlı sular
arasında göç eden balıkların bu göçleri
etkilenebilir
Çok uzağa gitmeyelim yine ülkemize bakın
endemik bir tür var
inci kefali Duydunuz mu nerede Van
Gölü'nde yaşıyor inci kefali nisan
ayında Van Gölü'nden bir akarsuyu
kullanarak göç ediyor
soğuk sulara
Temmuz ayında çıkan yavrular yumurtadan
çıkan yavrular tekrardan o akarsuyu
kullanarak Van Gölü'ne geliyor
Peki o Akarsu kurursa iklim değişikliği
nedeniyle bu göç gerçekleşir mi bu tür
ne olur
var mı yok olur Ha bir de şunu
söyleyeyim
sadece iklim değişikliği değil
canlıların birlikte yaşadığımız dünyayı
paylaştığımız canlıların tek sorununda
iklim değişikliği değil
O bahsettiğim akarsular
Biz Çiftçiler Biz insanlar suyunu
kestiğiniz zaman önüne barajlar
koyduğumuz zaman da yine göçleri
engelleyecektir Peki biz bunları
yaparken herhangi bir şekilde düşünüyor
muyuz onları
kuraklık deyince kuraklıkla mücadele
deyince her yere barajlar yapalım
diyoruz Peki bunu yaptığınız zaman
oradaki canlıların göçlerini
engelleyeceğimizi biliyor muyuz
düşünüyor muyuz ya da
tarımsal sulama için gölleri ve
akarsuları kullanırken
bu suları fazla kullandığımız zaman
oradaki canlıların suya ihtiyacı
olabileceğini hiç aklınıza getiriyor
muyuz Dolayısıyla
canlıların sadece iklim değişikliği
sorunu bakın sadece İkinci Dünya Savaşı
sonrasında
İnanılmaz bir şekilde sistemleri yok
ettik
abi tat değişimi diyoruz ormanları
kestik madene çevirdik suda kalanları
kuruttuk bir taraftan kirlilik var Şu
kirliliği toprak kirliliği plastik
kirliliği bir taraftan İnanılmaz bir
şekilde doğayı sömürüyoruz Örneğin aşırı
Balıkçılık sorunlarımız var bir de
İstilacı türler başladı balon balıkları
gibi Bütün bunlar da zaten hep beraber
canlıları tehdit ediyor ve iklim krizine
ek olarak Artık dünyada bahsediyoruz
ve Eğer sadece iklim değişikliği değil
Habitat değişimleri kirlilik aşırı
kullanım İstilacı yabancı türler gibi bu
faktörlerin ortak etkisiyle birlikte Az
önce bahsettiğim dünyada bulunan bizim
dünyayı paylaştığımız iki nokta bir
milyon kadar canlı türünün
üçte ikisinin 100 yılının sonuna kadar
yok olma riskiyle karşı karşıya
kalabileceği bakın çok ciddi bir rakam
üçte ikisi %67'si ne kadar yapar Kaç tür
yapar biliyor musunuz
bir nokta iki milyon tür yapar
çok yüksek miktarda
tabi
bugüne kadar da yine çok fazla
bilinmiyor yani bu kadar baskı altında
sadece iklim değişikliği çok sayıda
faktörün etkisi altında baskısı altında
türler
iklim değişikliğine bir canlı türünün
neslinin tükendiği kabul ediliyor onu
Duydunuz mu
O da ilginç bir hikaye dediler altın
kurbağa diye bir kurbağa türü var
bu altın kurbağa dediğimiz kurbağa Güney
Amerika'nın kuzeyinde oradaki tropikal
ormanlarda yaşayan bir tür ve Aslında
iklim değişikliğine bağlı olarak
sıcaklık artışlarıyla birlikte bir
mantar türü aşırı ürüyor ve bu kurbağa
türünün
dersine zarar verir onların böyle bir
nemli derisi vardır orada aşırı yürüyor
en son birey
1990'ların başında görüldü
ve dünyada iklim değişikliği nedeniyle
nesli tükenen ilk Türk kabul ediliyor
Ama tabii hangi türün Onun haricinde çok
sayıda
tür var ama bir türün iklim
değişikliğinden mi Yoksa diğer etkenler
nedeniyle mi tükendiğini söylemek zor
Çünkü aynı anda çok sayıda
olumsuz etkiler yapabiliyor şimdi
Hani bir de ormancıyım ben orman
mühendisiyim bir son bir örnekle şeyden
vereyim ağaçlardan bitkilerden vereyim
sedir ağaçlarının bilir misiniz
Toros sedir deriz
dünyadaki ilk yazılı destanda yer alan
bir ağaçtır ilk yazılı destan Gılgamış
Destanı
orada Gılgamış
katran ormanları denen bir orman
ormanlara gidiyor Onun bekçisi olan Hum
babayı öldürüp ağaçları kesiyor o
Kaptanın ağacı denilen ağaç sedir
ağaçtır toroslardı bulunuyor Bakın bu
sedir ağaçları
yaşlandıktan sonra ormanın gençleşmesi
fidanların çıkabilmesi için tohumların
kış aylarında karın üstüne düşmesi lazım
ve birkaç ay o tohumların karın içinde
soğukta beklemesi lazım çimlenebilmesi
için böyle Bazı bitkilerin tohumların
çimlenme engeli vardır soğukta
beklemezse sedir tohumları çimlenmez
Peki iklim değişikliğine bağlı olarak
dağlarımızda Karlar kar yağışları
azalıyor mu azalıyor O zaman en azından
tamamı olmasa bile sedir ormanlarının
düşük rakımlarında kar yağışı azalırsa
bu ormanların da geleceğe hazırlayabilir
ha bazı türlerde olumlu etkileniyor onu
da söyleyeyim
avantajlı türler var
Çevrenizde görüyorsunuzdur bazı türler
ise iklim değişikliğinden avantajlı
Örneğin Kent içinde tilkiler görmeye
başladık martıyı söyleyebilirim
bazı türler özellikle seçici olmayan
yani besin seçiciliği olmayan türler
iklim değişikliğinden avantajlı da
çıkabiliyor İstilacı yabancı türler
avantajlı çıkabiliyor çoğalıyor Çünkü
iklim değişikliğine bağlı olarak
canlılar Kuzey enlemlere ya da yüksek
dağlık alanlara göç edebiliyorlar şeyi
gösterecektim Genç nesil var burada
ıceed çizgi filmini hatırlarsınız
onlarla büyümüşsünüzdür yani ehliyeti
değil mi orada göç ediyorlar buz
devrinde
günümüzde de benzer göçler de ekleniyor
ama günümüzdeki Sorun ne canlıların göç
Yolları maalesef tıkandı yollarla kestik
yerleşimlerle kestik Bu da çok imkansız
ve sıcaklıklar inanılmaz hızlı
yükseliyor Bir canlının hayatı içinde
4-5 derece sıcaklığın artması söz konusu
ama işte İstilacı yabancı türler gibi
balon balıkları gibi çeşitler avantajlı
hale gelebiliyor sular ısındıkça daha
Kuzey enlemlere doğru gidebiliyor sadece
denizlerde değil karalarda da var
çeşitli böyle İstilacı yabancı türler
çeşitli böcek türleri Örneğin yılda bir
kere yumurtlarken
3 sıcaklıklar artınca 3 kere 5 kere
yumurtlamaya başladı bu da denemek
aşırıl üremeye başlıyorlar ve onunla
beslenen canlılar buna uyum sağlamazsa
yok olma riskiyle Daha doğrusu
zararlarını artırıp rekabete girdiği
türleri baskılayabilirler özetle sürede
bitiyor
hatim değişikliği sadece insanları etki
etmiyor
iklim değişikliği beraber yaşadığımız
tüm canlılara etki ediyor ve büyük bir
çoğunluğu da bundan olumsuz etkiliyor
şunu diyebiliriz İnsanlar biraz benciliz
Aman bize ne ben şeye bakarım bakın
bugün sıcak değil mi
iklimler değişiyor mis gibi püfür
klimalı odadayız serinliyoruz Peki
canlıların böyle bir şansı var mı ve biz
doğadaki canlılarla ekosistemlerle
göbekten bağlıyız
gıdalarımızın %90'ını Aslında
ekosistemlerden sağlıyoruz Onların çoğu
Aslında canlı
doğal ekosistemler bize afetlerden
koruyor hiç farkında olmasak da Seller
dönüyor heyelanları önlüyor kuraklığı
önlüyor ya da iklim değişikliğine
mücadele etmek için karbon vücutta
kalanları dediğimiz ormanlar suda
kalanlar denizler var Bunlar da
ekosistem
insanlar olarak sadece kendimizi değil
diğer canlıları da düşünmemiz lazım
Çünkü onların bize ihtiyacı var onların
kendi kendilerine değişen iklim
koşullarına uyma şansları çok fazla yok
Bu nedenle
değişim öncülük temalı bu toplantıda
sadece insanları düşünerek değil Bize
ihtiyacı olan diğer canlıları ve
ekosistemleri de düşünmemiz Onların da
iklim değişikliğinden daha az
etkilenmeler için hep birlikte
üretmemiz çözümler üretmemiz mücadele
etmemiz gerekiyor çünkü bu dünyada
yalnız değiliz teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]